u.s lifting a pandemic travel ban on
international visitors starting today
yeah big news the new rule is that they
must in fact show proof of vaccination
as well as a negative covet test bianca
hallman joining us live from mccarran
airport where we start or we're hoping
any way to start see that boost of
tourists come to our city bianca
hey good morning heather good morning
johnson this is great news for so many
people not only those who have family
abroad or want to go see family abroad
but also for our local economy here in
las vegas you know those travel
restrictions really hurt hotels
restaurants and retailers here in las
vegas so reopening the border to
international visitors who are traveling
for enjoyment will bring a positive
boost for those who do business abroad
this change comes just in time for the
holidays
it has been very difficult to get my
customers into the u.s but in most of
the cases what i have been doing is
traveling abroad to visit them for me
it's going to be very important to get
my business partners to visit me in the
us and i think that overall is a good
thing
now visitors must be vaccinated in order
to enter along with a negative cova test
within the past three days and if a
traveler is not vaccinated the covet
test must have been taken within one day
of departure miners those under 17 do
not have to meet this requirement so
it's also expected that airlines will be
adding more flights to accommodate those
international travelers definitely
needed during these next couple of
months during the holiday season bianca
holman live local now